former Health secretary Stephen Doral
Stephen Doral very good morning to you
first of all I wonder what you make of
these WhatsApp messages and what do they
tell us do you think about the
government's handling of the pandemic
well first of all the tone of individual
messages is obviously extremely
regrettable but I think there's a much
more a fundamental issue here which is
what it tells us about the way that the
government was making decisions at that
time nobody pretends that was easy but
the fact that it was a fast-moving
situation seems to me that it actually
emphasizes the need for proper process
in government decision making the Blair
government if you remember came under
Fire for what was called sofa government
informal decision making and it's
exactly the same thing it seems to me
that is being revealed here in these
messages as the way in which the Johnson
government was making decisions at a
time of when those decisions were of
huge importance to many millions of
families
Matt Hancock as you might imagine is
pretty unhappy about this he's described
it as being a biased account to suit an
anti-lockdown agenda he's making the
point this is a partial picture this is
the release of messages from one person
albeit an important person at the time
of the pandemic as the health secretary
but there's no details here of all the
other meetings and decision making that
would have gone on
I think that's completely fair and
that's part of the reason why I regret
the fact uh that the official inquiry
into the government's handling of the
circumstances at the beginning of the
pandemic has been so long delayed it was
a conscious political decision once
again by the Johnson government to
project this the the inquiry into the
future so that its conclusions wouldn't
be published before the general election
now I just doesn't seem to me that it
stands up for a member of that
government to come to a to put the
inquiry into the future and then say Oh
but this is biased that I absolutely
agree that what we need is a proper And
Timely it's it's already late but the
sooner the better uh inquiry into the
way in which these key decisions were
being made from what we can see from
these texts as I said it was another
manifestation of social government so we
know those methods don't work
Matt Hancock has made the point hasn't
he that the public inquiry is the place
for these WhatsApp messages he's saying
he's been completely transparent with
that inquiry do you think that's right
and that we should wait for that to run
its course or do you have concerns about
the pace of the inquiry
I absolutely have concerns about the
pace of the inquiry yeah I said I have
said many times I think that it's
important uh that in that this inquiry
Works quickly and examines all the
evidence Matt Hancock's rights to say
the only piece of evidence we that this
we're focusing on these text messages or
WhatsApp messages but there is what we
can't see is that the full range of uh
material available to ministers when
they were making decisions but what we
can see from these uh WhatsApp messages
is the way in which ministers were
reaching decisions uh and the some of
the prejudices that were being Advanced
during a decision-making process that I
think is extremely regrettable
given that you're worried about how long
the inquiry is taken are you grateful
then that these WhatsApp messages have
been published
well I think that I think I'm not sure
who it was who said it but I think it's
true uh that what this reveals is that
Isabel oakshot is a good journalist but
a bad friend
and more generally do you have worries
about what this story tells us and the
fact that it's in the public domain do
you think that it could be corrosive to
good government if if Government
ministers are worried all the time that
any messages that they have between them
might end up in the public domain no I
don't think that's a a legitimate worry
quite the contrary I think Ministers of
public officials and when they're making
decisions on the past on on behalf of
the public they should engage in a
properly disciplined process where the
argument and that's particularly true in
a fast-moving situation such as the as
we had at the beginning of the pandemic
I emphasize I'm not suggesting remotely
that these were easy decisions but that
should have made the proper process more
important not less important
was it a mistake for Matt Hancock to
hand over the WhatsApp messages to a
journalist why do you think he did that
well we know why he did it we did it
because he did it because he wanted to
have a story written for his book and
and she helped him go write that story
now to do that and to hand over material
to a journalists and the expector
journalist not to use it to pursue their
professional journalistic obligation
actually uh seems to me naive in the
extreme
I wonder if I could just get your
reaction to the news that the senior
civil servant Sue gray could be moving
to be uh sakeristarma's Chief of Staff
do you think that's an appropriate move
what do you make of it well actually you
know I think there's a very strong
linkage between these two stories
because the Public's only ever heard of
Sue gray because of the because of her
focus on proper process within
government and if kids Dharma is
appointing Sue gray as his chief of
staff I take that as a very strong
signal that KIA Stamo is committee to
proper process in government in a way
that Boris Johnson never was
and yet Boris Johnson and his supporters
are saying that this uh is not an
appropriate move they say well let me
quote Jacob Bruce Mark who tweeted so
much for an impartial civil service at
the gray report now looks like a
left-wing stitch up against atori PM do
you think this um hardens Boris
Johnson's argument about partygate does
it mean he's more likely to make a quick
return
no I don't think it does but I I think
what it does do is underlying uh Kia
stalma's commitment
it's evidence of kirstana's commitment
to a different way of managing
government business and that's something
I think every citizen of this country
should welcome
well Stephen Doral we appreciate your
time this morning thanks so much for
joining us today we we really appreciate
it thank you